let's talk about china all right we're
gonna talk about china because i really
want to talk about afghanistan but the
the big news is what the ripple of
afghanistan means for the rest of us
because of the failure in the withdrawal
from afghanistan i mean it's absolute
chaos they're trying to make it seem
like it's it's it's not good it's not
good china is taking advantage and we
have this article from the fake news
global times it's china's mouthpiece
saying update senator reveals 30 000 u.s
troops stationed in taiwan island equal
to declaring war on china if it's true
tweet deleted after wide controversy so
it seems that senator john cornyn just
didn't know what he was talking about
the taiwan number that there's 30 000
troops there apparently it's an old
number going back to the 70s or whatever
but china's not acting like it was just
a dumb tweet from someone who wasn't
paying attention they're trying to make
it seem like he revealed the information
look at this they say some others
believe the news leaked by the u.s
senator cannot be true because 30 000 is
not some small amount the us army could
hide and not being noticed on the island
and the u.s has nothing to gain by
stationing the u.s army in the island
sacrificing its own interest to satisfy
taiwan separatists also does not fit
with us foreign policy just like the us
did in afghanistan
talk about getting smacked around quite
a bit by china right now ouch yeah i
mean you don't usually see
the ccps and their mouthpieces being so
publicly um
i would just say you know trading barbs
back and forth especially in with you
know kind of operating within the news
cycle as we are right now so this is
definitely something new for the ccp
this is not something that you even four
years ago five years ago you would see
them doing only it's because now and i
think with xi jinping and his new thrust
for a more
uh a more aggressive china on the world
stage a more
you know we're not going to be
this we don't want to be viewed as a
third world country anymore so for years
and years and years we were told china
is still developing china is still you
know we're bringing our people out of
poverty we need all these programs but
then if you just look uh i believe
yesterday the financial times actually
had the story up that blackrock came out
and said that they want to increase
their investors exposure to china they
want people tripling their investments
in china that's blackrock because they
and they said that they have sort of
like an internal think tank there they
call it the blackrock investment
institute and they said we don't view
china as a developing country anymore
they are a fully developed nation and we
should treat them the same way as we
treat everyone else they are an engine
that is growing they are the future
that's essentially what black rock is
saying right and now china they are now
using this opportunity as a way to shrug
their shoulders off of sort of the what
you know what tony blinken or joe biden
might call the international rules based
order they're shrugging off the wto the
u.n etc everything else and they're
saying
we're not going to be pushed around by
you anymore we're going to push back
think about how long it's been that
china's been effectively just telling us
to shove it
where they know that
no matter what the u.s says it's always
a finger wag
so they're they're they're dumping all
this pollution they're producing massive
amounts of carbon while the rest of the
world is like hey we're going to stop
hey we've got these protocols we're all
going to agree to and china's like nah
no thanks or they say they will and then
they start building more coal power
plants you've got really dumb leadership
in the west where they're like it's okay
guys china said they're on board with
our programs and then china's laughing
like why would we ever actually do what
we said and it's been happening for a
really really long time that's a really
good description especially if you're
going to go into afghanistan later but
starting with china like as a country
they take themselves seriously yeah
there's another thing that china has
that america doesn't have right now is
that america is going through some sort
of identity crisis where it can't figure
out whether itself should exist anymore
i mean the scary thing is that's true
the perfect way to put it yeah like is
the perfect way to put it it's it's
going through internal mayhem why else
wouldn't china move if if you're
thinking about yourself as two players
on a chessboard and you're watching your
opponent run into dismay
if not aiding it somehow or at least
prodding it along i don't you know you
could say that one way or another i mean
you could ask questions of international
international influence and terrorism
and you could go out on those roads but
instead just in instead of just accusing
china of participating in domestic
terrorism within the world stage they're
like they will make an agreement that
they know they won't follow because they
don't respect you as an interlocutor
right right so what what essentially
you're talking about is this idea that
you know i don't think china china knows
that it's not into their best interest
to get into a shooting war with the u.s
right a kinetic warfare is not something
that would be really beneficial for
either side and so
that what is the most effective right
tool of their international foreign
policy for their interests is what you
would call strategic neutralization
right get the u.s so upset so divided so
screaming at each other so tied up in it
chasing its own tail in internal
domestic tensions that we are unable to
uh make a stand on the world stage and
we said that i came on here and said
that for a year on this show and i've
said it elsewhere and then you look at
afghanistan see we're so busy and i mean
it's almost a cliche right now but
you've got general milly talking about
white rage and we need to uh focus on
critical race theory etc etc and then
meanwhile it's like you can't even
conduct a basic evacuation operation of
your own or not even before that i i'm
getting ahead of myself you can't even
conduct a safe withdrawal of your own
forces right you didn't know that alone
not to be attacked which then set up
right this was supposed to be withdrawal
this wasn't supposed to be an evacuation
operation it's only be we're only
talking about evacuation because
it was a failure so for china this is
exactly what they want now they get to
backfill us in afghanistan now they get
to go after the rare earth minerals now
they get to buy up all that stuff of
course they're making a deal with with
the taliban however and this is my
assessment i've thrown it out there
i'll say it again tonight but
i think that you will see taliban
attacking china's one belt one road
infrastructure within or you know maybe
not specifically taliban but other
extremist elements over there within
five years
that's just the history of the region
that's the history of the peoples of
that region you do not see occupying
nations occupying forces doing well in
that part of the world and and there's a
lot of history about there's a i i have
a kind of a caveat unless china does
manifest the oppressor oppressed
narrative within the afghan people and
say this about that yeah it's not hard
you can like when when we were on the
ground we experienced that with the
locals oh you're ju you're not the
americans you're the oppressors
okay that's what they said when so first
yeah no no it's yeah it's already there
the the language is already invested in
the system
and they already have the easy example
of all america is the big bad
why wouldn't china
motivate that at that that cultural
aspect remember china the current
ccp was created by mao mao's china was
this idea of manifesting the political
disdain of the people for their own
government now you just use china doing
that on the world stage manifesting
govern countries or pseudo countries
against
ambiguous ideas like the west like rule
of law like america like i i i would not
be surprised i don't i think it buys
them a couple years i think i i think
they can get a couple years out of using
that very narrative and as well going
with the taliban and saying we they're
you know they are i don't think they've
officially recognized the taliban and um
kraken were wrong i don't believe anyone
has officially recognized them yet china
has come the closest but even then i
think it's something more they said like
we acknowledge the will of the afghan
people rather than we we recognize the
taliban's legitimate government so i
think it buys them a couple years
obviously it's it's in their best
interest taliban's interest to receive
if they can get any kind of deals with
china if they can get banking if they
can get all this because of course
you're seeing a lot of the international
community trying to shut down any uh
aspect of the taliban getting into the
finances of the government of
afghanistan being able to use any of
this stuff and so for china it creates
this sort of wellspring for them of
having that
ability to not have to use the
international system because they can
just go through china so china's tr as
you say they're trying to set themselves
up as we are the benefactor to go
against the big bad of the west and i do
think that'll buy them some time but
there's just 2 000 years of history of
afghanistan being the graveyard of
empires not to mention if they're going
to try and make it seem like oh the the
west is bad they're they're the real
enemies they're also trying to make the
world think that we've lost our power
their their their their attitude is the
us is fading the empire is collapsing
we're the big bad we're next
so i don't know if they would want to
convey that message simultaneously while
they're trying to convince everyone the
u.s is failing well robert tabor the
classic uh war of the flea i'm not i'm
not an expert on on on his work alone
but the introductory paragraphs are
insurgency is prolonged political
warfare
creating the spirit of revolution which
runs on the idea that it could happen
right so you don't so so afghanistan or
china does not endorse the taliban they
endorse the afghan caliphate right which
is the chinese puppet of
that attaches themselves to
movements like the nation of islam then
enters western countries and uses that
as a
backdoor road into
pushing more disdain for western values
and then the real question though is
what happens if and uh they are talking
about setting up an islamic republic um
or believe the islamic emirate i think
is the is the official name it's like
they're they're like republic no the
islamic american foreign
so how do you have an islamic emirate
but when right across your border with
china is what region of china xinjiang
yeah xinjiang which is i think three
times this that one province three times
the size of afghanistan nowhere near as
populated as afghanistan but it's
massively bigger than afghanistan and
you have one million weaker muslims also
sunni by the way
who are kept in concentration camps by
your same benefactor essentially you get
once you see these narrative conflicts
these contradictions i think are what
will eventually cause problems in this
relationship because china's going to
say well we're we're here to help you
okay but what about our you know our
friends our brothers that are within
your land that you are pressing so that
you can build your pipelines across
pakistan you know i've heard some
stories about what china is doing and i
kind of feel like the islamic emirate of
afghanistan would not mind
so i don't know if you've if you've
heard these stories that they when they
harvest organs from the the uyghurs they
can then sell them to arabic nations who
need organ transplants that are
you know yeah yeah i i don't know if
that's true if you're for anything so
essentially essentially what i'm saying
though is that
you will get you will still end up
getting breakaway groups right you're
still going to end up getting a group
there because this is the nature of
radical islam is that you will have a
group that says how dare we be in bed
with these guys how dare we go along
with this they are atheists they are
communists they are from the same stripe
as the soviet union when they tried to
impose communists on us now you're
trying to get in bed with a new the new
communists who oppress our people and
that's where you're going to get this
friction do you think with these threats
coming from china not only for the
military force against taiwan but also
to crush u.s troops assuming there are
any there i think we have like 20
there's like you know 20 military
personnel who are in taiwan for some
like training exercises
uh do you think this leads to war
um look i've i've you know i'm i'm sort
of like the proverbial
i don't think we're going to go to a
shooting war with taiwan anytime soon
over taiwan anytime soon
that being said it's possible right um i
don't think it's in china's best
interest i don't think it's in our best
interests again remember the plan right
the
we the axis of the elites between the
ccp and the one percent in the west we
want you to become the consumer nation
they want the west to be the consumers
of the world our inflated uh consumer
values our dollars we want you to buy
our tvs we want you to buy our iphones
everything that's made in china you you
are to consume that and be happy
remember right you'll own nothing and
you'll be happy yeah but that burst so
but it's still to your interest to
continue it going for as long as
possible yeah and then if we can if we
can condition down your to your point if
we can condition down your national will
your national identity if you don't feel
as strongly as being able to stand up
for your allies you'll then eventually
you'll get to the point to say well why
would we go to war over taiwan right who
cares about this thing and then so for
china's perspective again it's it's
similar to the to the taliban in a sense
there's that phrase that's been going
around this week you know you have the
watches but we have the time right right
so it was a hundred years for hong kong
and they
1897 to 1997 right and that handover of
taiwan is seen by the way
as the end of the british empire many
people see that as the end of the
british empires the symbolic act that
okay we are no longer this this
international what about empire what
about macau that's that's
china chinese yeah i think macau is 99
so that was that was uh portugal and
that was about two years later but hong
kong of course was the big one though
right if you actually look at it in
terms of um rev of local revenue i
believe macau is actually ahead i know
they're way above las vegas in terms of
gambling revenue that is the gaming
center of the world right now is macau
really oh yeah oh yeah and
and so and you better believe that a lot
of the companies from vegas are all
still operating in macau which means
they're all tied in with ccp as well and
so you've got a situation where
you know
to the ccp's perspective they want to
assimilate taiwan through osmosis the
strategy has been isolate
isolate them throughout the world cut
off their trade caught up their finances
right so if you land i've been you know
i've been in taiwan i've been on both
sides of the taiwan strait actually
and uh you know looked across you can't
see it but you know um
and so you when you land in the taipei
airport you know usually when you land
somewhere there's you see what's the
first thing you see is advertisements
right you see advertise it's usually
banks or some kind of real estate or
something like that
in the taipei airport there's none of
that right there's just a couple
pictures up of taiwan from like the
local you know mystery of tourism and
that's it so there aren't those huge
international brands
playing in taiwan the way that you'd see
everywhere else and why is that that's
because of economic isolationism that's
beijing going around telling everybody
you don't do business with this island
because we want their only economic
social and cultural vector to be through
us and if you want access to our markets
if you want access to be able to sell if
you want all the deals that we can offer
you right you have to cut off taiwan
that is the price you have to pay and
that's why if you go back to the 1970s
that is why
the u.s government recognized recognized
the government of beijing for the first
time for all those years throughout the
cold war we didn't recognize them
and it was carter who eventually
switched that over which then had the
pro had the the after effect of changing
the seat at the united nations which was
controlled by taiwan the republic of
china which was and is the legitimate
government of china uh prior to the ccp
then that seat at the u.n security
council went to communist china thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you